The Israel-Palestinian conflict.
It is so complex and emotionally charged
that most of us try to avoid it.
But if you're into history, it's a puzzle
that's hard to resist.
A story of empires, nationalism and
ancient claims that seem to
cry out for historical answer.
The problem is, even the most dedicated
students of history often build their
understanding on a foundation of myths.
Powerful, persuasive and historically
inaccurate stories that shape everything
that we think that we know.
What if I told you that the common belief
that this is an ancient religious war,
raging for millennia between Jews and
Muslims, is fundamentally wrong?
That the historical record actually
points towards a much more recent and
totally different origin story.
That's just one of the foundational myths
that we're going to tackle.
So, let's get into the five most
significant myths that you probably think
are true, and see why the historical
record proves them false.
Myth 1. An ancient religious feud.
The conflict is an
ancient, eternal holy war.
The story goes that Jews and Muslims have
been locked in a religious struggle over
the Holy Land for centuries.
It's an easy narrative because it writes
the whole thing off as an inevitable
clash of ancient hatreds.
This is simply not true.
The modern Israeli-Palestinian conflict
is a product of the late
19th and 20th centuries.
At its heart, it's a clash between two
competing nationalist movements born from
the collapse of the Ottoman Empire.
For centuries, under Ottoman rule, Jews,
Christians and Muslims coexisted in the
region with a degree of relative peace.
Your identity was more local and
religious than national.
That all started to change with the rise
of modern nationalism in Europe.
Two movements emerged
at roughly the same time.
Zionism, which argued that the Jewish
people were a nation deserving of a state
in their ancestral homeland,
and Arab nationalism, which sought
independence from Ottoman and later
European colonial rule.
Palestinian nationalism then grew as its
own distinct movement,
partially in response to the Ottoman
decline and partially in response to
increasing Zionist
immigration in the early 20th century.
So the conflict isn't about
the Quran versus the Torah.
It's about land, sovereignty and
self-determination between two groups who
see the very same territory
as their national homeland.
Framing it as an ancient religious feud
ignores the modern and political forces
that actually lead the fuse.
Myth two, the Jewish
connection to the land.
This claim is often used to frame the
conflict in a very specific way,
that Jewish people are foreign to the
Middle East and have no legitimate
historical tie to the land we now call
Israel and Palestine.
The argument basically says the Jewish
connection is purely religious, not
historical or ancestral.
Archaeological and historical records
tell a very different story.
Long before the rise of Christianity or
Islam, ancient Jewish kingdoms,
specifically the kingdoms of Israel and
Judah, were centered here.
We have inscriptions from neighboring
empires like Egypt and Assyria
that refer to these kingdoms.
The famous "Mernaptas" Tele, an Egyptian
artifact from the 13th
century before Christ,
contains the earliest known non-biblical
reference to Israel as
a people in the land.
Despite that and despite waves of exile,
a Jewish presence has remained in the
land continuously for thousands of years.
Archaeologists have uncovered countless
artifacts backing this up.
They've found royal seals with the names
of Judean kings mentioned in the Bible.
An Aramaic inscription found that Teldan
explicitly mentions the House of David,
proving that the Davidic dynasty was
recognized as a political reality by the
9th century before Christ.
After the Romans crushed the final Jewish
revolt in 135, they renamed the province
from Judea to Syria-Palestine,
a move many historians believe was a
deliberate attempt to erase the Jewish
connection to the land.
Despite that and despite waves of exile,
a Jewish presence has remained in the
land for thousands of years.
Teldanitis' connection isn't just
misreading history, it's denying
mountains of historical evidence.
Myth 3. Israel as a colonial project
This builds on the last myth, that the
state of Israel is just a European
settler colonial project, with no real
roots in the Middle East.
This narrative paints Zionism as another
branch of European colonialism and Jewish
Israelis as foreign invaders.
While modern political Zionism was
definitely influenced by 19th century
European ideas about nationalism,
calling it a purely European project
erases half of the story.
A huge portion of Israel's Jewish
population isn't of
European descent at all.
They are the Mizrahi and Sephardic Jews,
the descendants of Jewish communities
that had lived for centuries,
sometimes millennia, in the
Middle East and North Africa.
After Israel's creation in 1948, waves of
state sanctioned persecution and violence
were unleashed against Jewish
populations in Arab countries.
Fearing for their lives an estimated
850,000 Mizrahi and Sephardic Jews were
either expelled or fled from countries
like Iraq, Egypt, Yemen and Morocco.
Between 1948 and the early 1970s, nearly
600,000 of these
refugees poured into Israel.
These were not European colonizers, they
were Middle Eastern
and North African people.
Today, they and their descendants make up
roughly half of Israel's population.
Their story complicates the whole
European project narrative, revealing a
more complex picture.
The gathering of a global diaspora with
deep indigenous roots in the Middle East
finally back in their ancestral homeland.
Myth 4. The idea of Palestine.
Another pervasive myth
revolves around the name Palestine.
The claim goes that Palestine has always
been a distinct Arab country and that the
term "Palestinian" has always referred
only to its Arab inhabitants.
This suggests there was a continuous Arab
nation that was just
interrupted by Zionism.
Historically, that's not quite right.
The name Palestine
isn't even Arab in origin.
The Roman Empire imposed
it on the region around 135.
As mentioned, this was after they crushed
a Jewish revolt and it was a way to sever
the land's Jewish connection by naming it
after the Philistines, an
ancient enemy of the Israelites.
For the next 1800 years, Palestine was
just a name for a region, not an
independent country.
It was controlled by a series of empires.
The Romans, Byzantines, various Islamic
caliphates, crusaders
and finally the Ottomans.
During this time, a Palestinian was
simply anyone who lived there.
A Jew, Christian, Muslim.
In fact, until the mid-20th century,
Zionist organizations
used the term frequently.
The newspaper we know today as the
Jerusalem Post was founded by a Jew in
1932 as the Palestine Post.
The Palestine Symphony Orchestra, founded
in 1936 to save Jewish musicians from
persecution in Europe,
was a Jewish orchestra.
The exclusive identification of the term
Palestinian with the Arab population is a
much more recent development.
It solidified as a distinct nationalistic
identity in the 20th century, especially
after the Palestinian liberation
organization was formed in 1964.
This doesn't take away from the modern
Palestinian identity or their
nationalistic aspirations.
But it does make it clear that the idea
of an exclusively Arab nation state
called Palestine existing for centuries
just isn't historically accurate.
Myth 5. The Claim of Genocide
Finally, we have to address the most
serious and inflammatory claim of all,
that Israel is committing genocide
against the Palestinian people.
This accusation is no longer on the
fringes, it's part of mainstream
discourse and legal challenges.
The word genocide has a very specific
legal definition under the
1948 Genocide Convention.
To prove it, you have to show an intent
to destroy, in whole or in part, a
national, ethnical,
racial or religious group.
While the conflict has caused immense
suffering, death and displacement for
Palestinians, the legal question is
whether it meets that
incredibly high bar.
Those who argue that it is genocide point
to the high civilian death toll in
Israeli military operations, the blockade
of Gaza and inflammatory statements by
some Israeli officials
as evidence of intent.
However, other analysts and legal
scholars point to crucial evidence that
contradicts the claim.
Critically, the Palestinian population
has grown dramatically.
In 1948, the Palestinian population
worldwide was estimated
at around 1.4 million.
By 2023, estimates put that number at
over 14.6 million, a tenfold increase.
That demographic reality runs contrary to
the intent to destroy a population, which
is the core of the legal
definition of genocide.
Israel maintains that its military
actions are aimed at Hamas,
not the Palestinian people.
Even with the devastating and tragic
civilian casualties that occur, the
debate over whether these actions
constitute war crimes is a
valid and necessary question.
But as for genocide, the legal question
is still very much contested.
While many legal experts agree that the
high bar of intent to destroy has not
been met, the issue is being actively
debated in international forums in 2025,
and no international court has given a
definitive ruling yet.
Look, digging into these myths isn't
about picking a side, or saying one
group's suffering
matters less than another's.
It's about clearing the fog.
These narratives aren't
just historical mistakes.
They are weapons in an information war
that make a very complex reality nearly
impossible to grasp.
They can turn a modern nationalist
conflict into an eternal religious war.
They can erase one people's history while
misrepresenting another's.
And they can deploy one of the most
severe accusations without meeting the
rigorous threshold for evidence.
A more informed conversation doesn't
start with more anger,
but with more accuracy.
It begins by setting aside the convenient
myths and confronting the
messy, complex historical record.
The truth is rarely as simple as the
stories that we are told.
If you value these kinds of historical
deep dives, be sure to subscribe.
And please share your
thoughts in the comments below.
Thank you for listening.